ich habe mitgebracht ein thema was mich
sehr bewegt nämlich der volksentscheid
in berlin zum thema enteignungen
enteignungen von wohnungen der großen
konzerne und es macht mich wirklich
nachdenklich wenn jetzt bis zu 36
milliarden euro dafür ausgegeben werden
sollen um wohnungen anzuwerben das sind
10.000 euro pro person in berlin die das
ganze kostet und dadurch entsteht keine
einzige neue wohnung deswegen halte ich
das für falsch ich glaube dass wir eher
dafür darüber sprechen müssen dass wir
neuen wohnraum schaffen dass wir
investieren und schauen ob nicht mehr
wohnraum durch beispielsweise die 50.000
dachgeschosswohnungen die ausgebaut
werden könnten vielleicht eher dadurch
entstehen lassen und damit noch in
wohnraum schaffen und wenn ich dann sehe
dass die großen spd verbände sich dafür
aussprechen eine rot rot grüne koalition
zu machen dann scheint die
bürgermeisterin die feier zur einheit
items bürgermeisterin zu werden dieser
volksentscheid war von langer hand
geplant kommt aus der linkspartei heraus
auch aus der interventionistischen
linken die übrigens rande amt am rande
der legalität steht aber die frage ist
doch wo die gegenoffensive geblieben ist
und das betrifft auch ihre partei also
haben wir denn wirklich darauf geachtet
was da auf uns zukommt leute wurden mit
dieser frage konfrontiert wollt ihr dass
eure wohnung in privatbesitz ist wollt
ihr dass ihr für die rendite von
eigentümern bezahlt und sie haben dann
in der mehrheit gesagt das wollen wir
nicht aber vielleicht auch nur deswegen
weil sie nicht informiert genug waren
und wo war denn die gegenoffensive der
wohnungswirtschaft das kann ich sie
nicht fragen aber vielleicht auch der
cdu
war da ein schweigen im walde da haben
sie sich gewehrt er hinterher können wir
immer sagen das ist falsch gewesen ist
rief gelaufen aber man konnte doch
vorher schon sehen wo die wo es hin
laufen würde also ich habe schon gesehen
dass im wahlkampf um das
abgeordnetenhaus in berlin die cdu sehr
sehr klar dort auch gestanden hat und
dass sie sich auch klar positioniert hat
kai wegner hat immer klar position
bezogen und deutlich gemacht dass er
gegen diesen volksentscheid ist aber die
einzigen wo man zeit nachschärfen müsste
weil die anderen den politischen gegner
die spd auch da festzunageln und
klarzustellen macht ihr das mit oder
macht ihr es am ende eben nicht mit vgv
wacker dort rum und hat sich jetzt am
ende wird sie sich wahrscheinlich jetzt
über stimmen lassen es reicht hier nicht
aus der gegend zu sein sondern dann muss
die wir etwas entgegensetzen also diese
diese parole ich nehme den das eigentum
weg und dann wird alles besser und alles
gerechter ist ja sozusagen also als wohl
gern marxismus immer verfängt das ja gut
ich also das heißt dagegen zu sein ist
das ist es ja nicht du musst ein
gegenkonzept entwickelt das habe ich
nicht gesehen hat dass hier jemand
vielleicht bemerkt ist einmalig sagt
hätte das will ich der cdu und der fdp
diesmal wirklich nicht vorwerfen ich
habe irgendein problem mit berlin und
zwar nicht nur beim thema enteignung
aber da da kommt das wirklich das
gipfelt dieser ganze irrsinn aber wir
erleben ja eine hauptstadt die einfach
nicht funktioniert und zwar bei gar
nichts jeder der seinen personalausweis
erneuern möchte muss monatelang auf
einen termin warten der neue flughafen
absolutes desaster und die regierung die
dafür verantwortlich ist wird einfach
jedes mal wiedergewählt ich frag mich
was stimmt mit den berliner nicht auch
dass sie jetzt plötzlich für enteignung
stimmen ich meine das ist doch die stadt
die jahrzehntelang sozialismus erlebt
hat und kaum gibt man volksentscheid in
dem man wieder ein bisschen mehr
sozialismus sich wieder zurückholen
möchte stimmt ja auch noch dafür aber so
hätten doch nicht nur die berliner
gestimmt denn wenn die wohnungsnot so
groß ist wie sie ist und wenn die mieten
so hoch sind wie sie sind das eine
normale familie sich gar keine wohnung
mehr leisten kann und dann erzählt die
rheiner ja wenn wir den weg nehmen dann
sinkt deine miete ja natürlich wenn ich
da nicht nicht lange überlegen und
vielleicht auch nicht so gut informiert
bin wie die wir hier ab dann dann sag
ich doch ja da haben sie recht die miete
muss herunter es ist doch kein berlin
problem wenn du magst berlin
vielleicht
habe ich habe schon gestellt und ich
muss zugeben dass ich diese abstimmung
gesehen habe die diskussion auch in den
öffentlich rechtlichen medien dazu
befasst die schuhe ausgezogen wie
unkritisch eigentlich auch die
öffentlich-rechtlichen journalisten über
dieses thema daher berichtet haben aber
vielleicht muss man diese entwicklung
von berlin als teil eines größeren
vielleicht sogar internationalen trend
sehen dass diese städte diese zentren
immer stärker von rot-grünen zusehens
ideologischen parteien beherrscht werden
die sich dann ihre eigene klientel hier
richtige hin züchten indem sie den
vergünstigungen geben sagen wir nehmen
dem genius seine wohnung weg und geben
sie den mann gibt dem fritz 30 prozent
weniger dann ist zumindest der fritz
zufrieden und dann hat man am schluss zu
einer fremdfinanzierte freiluft wege
rot-grün beherrscht und es ein trend den
wir auch in der schweiz beobachten und
das ist eine wichtige aufgabe glaube ich
für die bürgerlichen parteien dass man
hier wieder an die grundsätze erinnert
des erfolgs in deutschland ich glaube
das scheint mir heute ganz wichtig sein
was ist marktwirtschaft soziale
marktwirtschaft was heißt das eigentlich
was ist die bedeutung des eigentums aber
ich fürchte dass die städte tatsächlich
zu so rot grünen ideologie biotopen
werden und die landschaft die
landbevölkerung ziehen ja auch einige
leute immer mehr da in die umgebungs
gebiete hinaus dass dort eigentlich dann
der gesunde menschenverstand außerhalb
der städte das marktwirtschaftliche
bewusstsein residiert aber ihr müsst auf
journalisten auch in der stadt als
einsam mit und wie schaut's des eigenen
willens mühlen da der rot-grüne politik
mit der hand schreiben
der gleichheit aller herrschen aber das
macht ja
da hat er recht es muss grundsätzlich
werden sie haben vom eigentum gesprochen
welche rolle spielt das einst für die
soziale marktwirtschaft
es ist nämlich von 5.000 eigentum zu
haben ja darf dann ja gar nicht mehr
sagen nein das ist passiert und das ist
auch die intention um bei ihren
rot-grünen seilschaften zu bleiben wie
die innenstädte beherrschen das ist die
intention dieses ganzen volksbegehrens
und dessen was dahinter steht die
initiatoren sagen ja jetzt schon als
nächstes nehmen wir uns die
energiewirtschaft dran und dann gucken
wir mal dann kommen die bauern
vielleicht noch die autoindustrie wieder
daran gestorben das heißt sehr wichtig
dass wir grundsätzlich werden dass wir
sagen was bedeutet eigentum und die
unantastbarkeit des eigentums für das
funktionieren unseres wirtschaftssystems
philipp hat ein kubaner recht als
eigentum heutzutage schon verpönte ist
es zu haben absolut ich und ich frage
mich was die cdu tun will um diese
erzählung wiederzubeleben die
deutschland über jahrzehnte auch so
stark gemacht hat und die rot grüne
städte da hat der kuppel absolut ein
punkt und das wird natürlich auch alles
medial zu gewissen teilen mit befeuert
aber heran was wollen sie eigentlich
dagegen tun um die städte und die
modernen menschen wieder
zurückzugewinnen na ja es geht ja schon
darum auch die frage können wir den
leuten sagen ihr könnt auch wieder
eigentum schaffen wollen wir denn nur
noch das eben größere investoren in die
großen städte kommen und dort ihre und
dort investieren und die als vermieter
auftreten da wollen wir nicht auch dass
jeder einzelne mal wieder wohneigentum
schaffen kann für sich so und da sehe
ich natürlich schon dass wir den großen
städten erhebliche probleme haben ein
guter freund von mir wohnt in münchen
mit seiner frau beide verdienen wirklich
gut und können sich trotzdem keine
wohnung in münchen leisten und dann
haben wir natürlich schon ein
ernsthaftes problem
und dann müssen wir auch über sprechen
wenn wir am ende 15 bis 20 prozent
nebenkosten haben was kann denn auch der
staat dafür tun deswegen haben wir uns
ja als junge union sehr dafür eingesetzt
die cdu jetzt ins wahlprogramm
aufgenommen das erste selbst genutzte
eigenheim von der grunderwerbsteuer zu
befreien und an dieser stelle eben auch
anreize zu liefern zusagen
eigentumsbildung ist für dich auch
altersvorsorge das ist doch der richtige
schritt und dann muss die union wieder
viel stärker hin weil es für mich eine
frage des aufstiegs ist eine frage des
sozialen aufstiegs zu sagen du kannst
für dich eigentum bilden du musst dich
eigentum erben es geht nicht darum leute
zu haben die erben sondern es geht darum
dass du etwas schaffen kannst für dich
ja mal ein bisschen vor der frage jetzt
gedrückt wie ist das eigentlich mit den
mieten nicht also das ist ja das was das
ganze so befeuert die mieten sind zu
hoch bleiben wir die antwort schuldig
was wie wie soll es eigentlich
weitergehen in den städten haben ein
seriöses interessant scheint mir zu sein
und das habe ich etwas vermisst im
deutschen wahlkampf die thematik dass
man hier nicht die spd viel stärker auch
gebrauchen hat sie haben das jetzt
gemacht mit fragiler sie haben gesagt
die eier darum und das war für mich
interessant man hat sich dann etwas auf
die linkspartei eigentlich eingeschossen
aber die spd ist ja voll drauf bei den
bei der einschränkung der
eigentumsrechte dass du als
unterstreicht aus wohnungsbesitzer noch
die wohnung haben ganz aber dass so viel
einschränkung dass die über dein
eigentum nicht verfügen kannst und jetzt
kommt eben das andere problem wenn das
natürlich passiert dann haben sie am
schluss sein korruptes system weil
entscheident politische aktivitäten über
die wohnungsvergabe das ist dann aber
für die journalisten wieder dann können
sich so viele missstände aufdecken und
zeigen werde ihm wer wen dann da eine
günstige wohnung zu ernst und zu kommt
aber aus sicht eines bürgers ist das
eine tragödie weil sie sehen dass hier
wirklich ein filz sich dann ausbreitet
ein rot-grüner immobilien filz der mit
diesem wohnraum dem mann wurden
enteignet hat seine eigenen
wählerschichten da immer wieder belohnt
auf kosten der arbeitstätigen
bevölkerung das ist die tragödie aber
das ist noch mal was ist eure aufgabe
hier den leuten die augen 12 mit der
allerdings so schlau wie zuvor jetzt
wissen wir sind ja immer noch nicht aus
der frage aus wie man sich denn eine
wohnung in münchen leisten solltest da
kommen wir jetzt ja so nicht weiter gut
die frage ist also wieder eine wohnung
kaufen kann ich muss doch auch aktien
los angeles keine villa k
[Musik]